customers love the cloud but they are
afraid that when they applauded by to
the cloud that we will leak their secret
information the new way in which people
are thinking is that let's keep all the
data encrypted as much as possible so
that even if people break into the cloud
they're just going to see a good data
and because of that there the hackers of
the adversity is not going to learn
anything because the customer is going
to keep the keys and the data is going
to be in the cloud or always almost
always encrypted guarantee two important
things one is data confidentiality we
cannot in our cloud systems see the data
that customers a blow to our cloud and
it also has another interesting property
we cannot we can guarantee that the
cloud operator cannot temper with the
results of the computation so when when
their customers get the results they can
verify that the results are correct the
most interesting thing about cloud
security is that there now is you mean
that maybe the mission can get
compromised but even then can we give
security and we're using encryption far
more pervasively than everyone so in
that sense right what is exciting to me
as a researcher is that this is a
completely different way of thinking
about about security it's not about
securing the whole machine it's about
securing your data even if your machine
gets compromised